look let's be honest i said i was going
to release a document
and um clearly we haven't
uh okay april
we're fools about uh universal theories
of everything perhaps a new one
created by today's guest eric weinstein
uh and that goes by the moniker
geometric unity
we're talking about is crazy
i think it's really important to just
own up to the fact that for people who
want
sober physics this is probably not the
channel for you today
um
we looked at our history everybody who's
proposed new physical law
uh and gotten it right had errors
the the problem is is that we're not in
an adult phase where we faced
up to the fact that we have almost 50
years of stagnation
and what you're seeing with this
proliferation of
new claimants to have fundamental
theories
is in part that string theory has
finally weakened itself
and the aging of the particular um
cohort which is baby boomers who are the
string theory proponents
they've gotten weak enough that
effectively other people
feel emboldened i think you know stephen
wolfram said this recently that
in a previous era he would have expected
to have been attacked
but we've been waiting around for so
long that perhaps
the political economy of unification and
wild ideas
has changed somewhat what are the inputs
there are the players the matter
players there are the the gauge bosons
there are
new predictions there are new uh new
concepts
but there's a lot of weirdness why why
the lorentz group
why su-3 cross su-2 cross u1 for the
internal symmetries generating the
forces why three families
and i i thought that
something that many younger viewers uh
may not be aware of
is that things really changed
around nineteen
and if you think about the original
anomaly
uh cancellation of green and schwartz in
1984 i believe
um you could ask what was physics like
right before that moment
and i think it's absolutely shocking
because we don't realize the extent to
which the string theorists really
redefined
what the major problems in physics were
i think most people in the post-string
era
somehow believe that the major issue is
quantum gravity
and i don't really i i just find it
astounding because that's really what
the string theorists were selling so i i
think that a lot of things got done to
shore up
what we do to mature input into a
quantum theory
it just it wasn't physics per se it was
sort of the mathematics of physics
and i think that that was very
frustrating which is
you know it's sort of to physicists it's
yeoman's work they wanted to go to
stockholm
uh and they ended up you know winning
the first
fields medal won by a physicist and i
think
it's weird it's it's like what is your
time your time is whatever it is
that can be done and they thought their
time was to quantize gravity well
guess again nature said we have
something incredibly important so i feel
like
i'm trying to rescue their legacy they
want to go down as
string theorists for the most part and
they want to say that string theory was
the more successful most successful of
any claimant maybe that structure
ultimately carries the day
but i do think that the idea that
they're entitled to this many pivots
without having to become self-reflective
is preposterous what do you say to the
younger people who say they
they can't understand it they can't
comprehend geometric unity
we can say what geometric unity actually
is we can draw
pictures people can get it and in fact
i was talking to my good buddy joe rogan
earlier today
and a particular group of
people who listened to my podcast to put
up a site
for joe called pull that up jamie
dot com jamie could you bring up
something called boskin
wild versus mild i know what you're
saying
because i want to be joyous i want to
produce
positive things that uplift us to give
us a hope
of breaking like the einsteinian speed
limit you know if this is wrong
i want to know we've had insufferable
members of our community for a very long
time and we should not be getting rid of
insufferable people
the problem is what happens when people
become insufferable
and they don't constantly check in with
the unforgiving nature of the universe
we have a problem that sociologically
nobody wants to say that the institute
for advanced study has
like the smartest guys around and a lot
of what they do is in physics
in standard terms it's the mathematics
of physics
and that these are uncomfortable truths
just the same way that
it's uncomfortable that we're taking
seriously somebody who's been out of the
field for 27 years
but these are these are end times we're
having end time conversations and i
think that it's it's
you know we don't need to be mean about
it i think it just needs to be more
honest that ship that you're seeing
is called curvature and it has three
masts because it has
three irreducible components usually one
mast is called vial curvature
one mast is called traceless richie
curvature
and one mast is called richie scalar
and the first greatest insight
maybe of the 20th century was the way in
which we could feedback the curvature of
the levitovita connection
into being a co-vector field on the
space of all metrics
and this is depicted as a boat going
into a bottle that has a rather wide
opening
so we've got a metric the metric has a
connection the connection produces
curvature that's romanian we find that
by identities it's got
three components it tries to go towards
metrics and the vial curvature is
snapped off
afterwards the scalar curvature is
lowered somewhat or adjusted
by scalar curvature over two times g mu
nu
and so symbolically what we've done is
we've said
einstein threw away the vial curvature
readjusted the richie scalar curvature
and fed
metric information through to the love
echovita connection
through to the riemann curvature tensor
and then play these projection games to
feed it back to the space of metrics and
that particular combination
is perpendicular to the action of the
diffumorphism group on the space of all
metrics
uh leading to a divergence-free
condition
via the friend the bianchi identity so
let's see whether general relativity
engaged theory have an incompatibility
problem
as we try to play the same game we start
off with the riemann curvature tensor
but now the neck
is narrower and what's really going on
is is that this is kind of evocative of
trying to feed it into the space of
connections
but the gauge group acts
differently on two different factors
namely
if connections are ad valued one forms
and
curvature is a an add or a lee algebra
value to
form the problem here is
that gauge transformations act on the
lee algebra component and don't
touch the form component but einsteinian
projection or contraction or summing
over
g mu new indices is democratic
it deals simultaneously with the form
piece and the lee algebra
piece so if you treat only the lee
algebra piece under a gauge
transformation
you don't touch the form piece then
contraction
followed by gauge transformation will
never be the same thing
as gauge transformation followed by
contraction
so here's a gu approach how do you get
geometric
harmony between general relativity and
gauge theory
when you have the ship in a bottle
problem and this is kind of almost a
tight analogy you've got the curvature
tensor
you apply a gauge transformation to two
of the masts
and you pass them through into
add valued uh d minus one forms and then
you do an inverse gage
transformation which is exactly how you
do the ship in the bottle trick by the
way brian gave me a wonderful shipping
bottle thank you very much
raising the math inside and then you can
potentially if need be
adjust one of the two masts again in
order to get agreement
so in part the the idea is
how do you get harmony
[Music]
let's imagine that we have a salary that
is constant
in dollar terms over time but somebody
is facing
uh inflationary pressures on their
basket of goods what we now have
is a 10 an hour salary and if we claim
that it's constant constant means
derivative
equals zero yes
but we know that it's not constant
purchasing power
so we have two notions of constancy how
are they related
we do a gauge transformation you now see
that these little
hash lines are the reference levels that
we call a connection
and we decide that rise over run
should not be measured from a naive
horizontal but should be measured
instead from a custom reference level
represented by the hash mark that
situation
is actually an application of gauge
theory to a very simple problem in
economics
completely depicted by stretching the
fibers in the x
y plane
toy model of space time so
going around through the center is like
groundhog day you come back
to the same place and it's a repeating
time cycle
and space is simply a circle what you're
seeing here is something that's very
hard to picture because it's five
dimensional but one one trick here is
because the torus has a property called
parallelizability
the object on the right is a potential
metric
at any given point on the torus
so in other words if a metric is a
symmetric
non-degenerate two tensor if you think
of it as a matrix
it would be of the form x
z z y
and the k nondegenerate means that
x y minus z
squared is not equal to zero so that's
what's cutting out that variety if you
will the zeros of the det
of the determinant uh would be points
given that there are three degrees of
freedom in the metric
and so instead of actually having a
metric
uh space time
gu would say replace the torus
by the entire space in that sort of hour
glassy region
so the top region would be like space
space metrics
the bottom below that sort of weird uh
diaphanous
scarf is time time metrics
and the weird middle region
which is sort of around that singularity
would be space time metrics
every way you can stick that doughnut
into that middle region without touching
one of those two sheets
is a valid space time metric
and what gu would do is to say don't
only dance on the points of the
two-dimensional taurus
you should actually have fields that are
dancing on
all of the points of the taurus and
simultaneously all of the points in that
middle region
now notice that thing up in the top left
which is a ruler protractor combination
those two sliders are recalibrations of
what it means to be one unit
and that protractor is a recalibration
of what you're going to define to be 90
degrees so every way of keeping that
bottom arm
in a single horizontal position moving
the top arm and moving the two sliders
that's one of that's three degrees of
freedom in the space of metrics
so that's a different depiction of the
space of metrics
so the big take home from the
restrictive version of gu that we're
exploring here
is that if you allow fields to dance on
the space of
metric apparatus measurement apparatus
that
the kind of the paradoxes of
measurements start to make a lot more
sense
so the thing is is that spinners on 14
look like spinners on four tensor
spinners on some version of 10.
yeah and whether you're talking about
spin 10 models su-5 models or
su4 cross su-2 process u2 which is spin
6
cross spin 4 isn't that exactly what we
see in the standard model
a particularly intriguing feature of
so10 which is really spin 10 or could be
spin 6 comma spin 4 is its spinner
representation
used to house the quarks and leptons in
which the states have a simple
representation in terms of basis states
labeled by a set of plus and minus signs
perhaps this suggests composite
structure now here's the sentence that
just floored me
alternatively one could wonder whether
the occurrence of spinners both in
internal space and in space
time is more than a coincidence and then
he pulls back immediately
these are just intriguing facts they are
not presently incorporated in any
compelling theoretical framework as far
as i know
geometric unity is that compelling
framework and one of the things i'm
looking to do is i'm looking to get
constructive feedback from people who
want to help me succeed as opposed to
people
who just want to be dicks and what i
would love is to bring your positive
energy
go to geometricunity.org
physics is the most honest way
to ask the most grand questions in the
universe
absolutely physics is granulos then
we've got real problems and grand
doesn't exist and if grand doesn't exist
then grandiose doesn't exist so my
feeling is no
this is the actual grand quest and we're
not going to back off it and
be [ __ ] about it